5 youtube et bienvenue pour cette
nouvelle vidéo salut vlad ça le coeur
serré tout le monde donc vlad
on va regarder ensemble maintenant la
partie décisive du grand prix riga donc
il pouvait offrir en cas de victoire une
énorme option pour maxime pour la
qualification aux candidats et c'était
une partie armageddon donc c'est la
dernière partie du tour noire il ne peut
pas en être autrement
peut-être à fouetter l'expliquer les
règles doivent embarquer dans ouais
alors les blancs ont cinq minutes contre
4 minutes pour les noirs mais les blancs
sont obligés de gagner la partie pour
gagner le tournoi en cas de nul ou de
victoire des noirs c'est mamediarov donc
en l'occurrence qui remporte ce grand
prix est à noter que pour éviter une fin
de partie complètement salle où les
pièces vols à partir du 61ème coup il ya
un incrément blad et donc d'après ce que
j'ai lu je suis pas sûr à 100% mais
c'est mamediarov qui a eu le choix des
couleurs et qui a appris les noirs enfin
en tout cas c'est pas déjà d'après ce
que je sais presque tout le monde
choisit les noirs capter il faut choisir
les couleurs conquois chacun pense
kocaman le fait d'avoir un mois
d'octobre quand même plus que compensé
par le fait qu' on peut se dire une
version longue ovation c'est dans la
partie maxime qui commence par cavaye f3
donc il avait joué beaucoup d'italiennes
et 4 jusqu'ici et il change pour cette
armageddon set sauvant son arme dans
l'es14 rapide
tout simplement parce qu'il veut donc
que au niveau joue soit moitié oric
conquois - m6 a plus peur c'est devenu
théorique et vous verrez que me sens
très bien dans ce que le jeu est à noter
une petite chose maxime qui était en
confiance avant la partie puisqu'il
était revenu dans le match en gagnant
avec les pièces noires le blitz donc ils
venaient de requins dans la manière il
s'était sauvé donc le
le côté psychologique des plutôt en
faveur du joueur français dont cavalière
trois caves à 9,6 g 3g si ce fou j'ai
deux foulées cette c4 rock donc la tête
là on va se faire en mode rapide en
vidéo des cadets 6 donc on s'en fout ici
il faut quand même mentionné à moi de
donner du crédit à chaque créateur qui
ôte dans les situations où les veaux bio
en cuir de hognoul il a quand même joué
rien c'est agressif parce qu'il ya
d'autres plus sécure pour le noir par et
celles avec des six colis de 7-5 1-6
dirait conseil qui débute un jeune noir
un jour cf les six mois donc c'est une
bonne approche un général comme vous
jouez pour faire nul n'est pas se
réjouit éric femme quand vous les faire
nul ne pas compliquer ses troupes ont
joué normalement là sachant toujours qui
nous serons donc il y aura cavani péter
scène et a maintenant un couteau et oui
c'est digne de petits qu'eux petite
explication parce que c'est criard et
les autres jeux à 0 on jouait beaucoup
de parties après 10 ans de quatre rôles
dans ce dès que les ti cats de 8 h 3 à 6
et après les noirs jouent turbo id ce 5
2 5
donc ça c'est un genre des taux de marc
auxi avec les blancs mais contre une
structure d c'est pas comme dans les
sicilienne on joue contre cette
structure de pions et à mon avis ça
change beaucoup de choses mais on n'est
pas fini les noirs vu une chose peut
prouver qu une fois le faucheux dossier
sur jeune homme et a plus eu les fermes
et les baumes purves entamant une
activité sur les deux dames 5 5e
je dois contrôler par voie d'accord et
noir veulent attaquer ouais et donc dans
le sud ossète autrement ça monte pour
les durées reddition de maxime parce que
après eux des cavaliers de 4.8 le mont
blanc short et un assist de trois tours
donc il fait exactement le même plan ça
vous donne ici c'est pas trop bon parce
que le fou le feu le fou met le feu le
fou crache du feu ou le crash du fou
jusqu'à 1 tu veux en fait c'est dyson
d'argos en fait c'est daenerys pas où
john snow et c'est le dragon quoi et le
dragon quand ils arrivent pas vu la
femme de les séries vu la fin de la
série qu'on ne se parle pas vu la fin de
la série on ne sait pas ouais on est en
tout cas le dragons crachent du feu pour
le monde bien sûr je fais craquer
maintenant alors que valeo 5 mai
d'habitude le pion sur ceux souvent le
close sur ce cas très amer en ce moment
pas ici
et deuxièmement comme les blancs sont
parfaitement modélisés déjà parfaitement
les bornes pour jouer ce sac tout dessus
et sa pêche complètement le point noir
du jeu c'est simple que ça parce que moi
tu n'as aucun cd c'est une ménagerie
sais si je suis sur des seuils crise et
6 par an où est sinon c'était c'est une
menace parce que la tempête gare de
l'est la torride atteint puisque ces
décès d on veut pas le faire ne pas se
retrouver avec un pion à l'arrière donc
des 5 alors logique en forme tout le
monde de jouer de sa dans cette position
là là c'est un moment dans la partie où
on les entendait on est on est très
patient parce qu'avec la don nées en
perruque lunettes j'ai envie de te dire
maquillage on est chaud et la pelade
eagle quoi le gac maintenant e4 bien sûr
pourquoi parce que si après avocate les
noirs jouent si justes ils prennent le
pionnier qui avait laissé six mois avec
quand même
louis van gogh ou encore un matériel
j'ai pas aimé donc et française histoire
quand des 80 ans des 8,4 com
admettons sens n'a pas regardé à leur
dis ok sinon si les noirs josse et 6
attends je reviens donc dire oui les 126
6 et 6e des cavaliers à 4 ya pas mal de
simples escarmouches il doit surtout
depuis les 5 g bien l'auteur cheval voix
sur précise qu'après s'être des quatre à
quatre des cinq on envoie à latouille un
problème qua non les blancs sont bien
ses balles est pas égal et il est
évident que l héroïne pure de vougeot 4
- après trois mois on nous l'enlève la
première vente de leur vie d'ailleurs un
peu parce que le foot parce que eux deux
car les deux 5e relais de 5,25 eur
c'est un peu pareil sinon donc les noirs
doivent rentrer dans peut-être une autre
ligne compliqué mais toujours moins bien
concéder on en est venus ici mise car il
y six tours des huit tours des 8 change
et cafetiers id4 mais ici on fait
n'importe qui le couvrent de l'étang
correct comme dans celle d'un coup
d'envoi dont toujours un peu davantage
quoi bon la position reste un peu
compliqué tout de même mais bien sûr on
ne peut pas avoir fait remettre quand
même un avantage matériel est vrai un
acteur à ségo donc au lieu de ça ils les
joueurs
h3 assez rapidement donc cela
prophylactique contre toi comme moi hier
quatre mois le problème c'est que le
coût n'est pas trouvons ici je pense que
le meilleur coût pour le vent cette
denrée l'inra c'est la danse à partir
d'alcool pourquoi parce que le noir
utilise le fait que voler de s'accoler
de 5-fu de 5 n'est plus possible
à voir donc donc plus rien du tout parce
que forget pas justement h3 c'était pas
trop utile et même
poker qui comme moi je crée un jeu assez
rapide mac os x et si oui bon faut que
faut noter bien un truc important c'est
qu'il ya vraiment pas leur ajoutant donc
c'est dur à gérer son temps parce
qu'avec les noirs tu sais que tu te
retrouves mal autant les blancs ils vont
pouvoir te thabeet c'est donc c'est
compréhensible car valeo 4 12 nouveaux
donneurs bo3 oui le cadre de nouveaux
bonbons il n'a pas à jouer l'afrique et
ses six premiers français 6e 4 - 2 5 est
assez défendue par le pion sais si je
mange les besoins sont toujours vives
- mon mothma c'est quand même moins
forcé parce que 2,5 et défendus ou pose
que donc les noix pour traîner avec le
bio sur 2,5 en quoi faut 6 et là c'est
un peu le coup qu'on a vraiment
regretter le premier moment on a
commencé à avoir un peu peur pour maxime
toi tu cries et qui avaient lieu deux
car il y ait des quatre on s'en prend
pioncer 6 et sebaaoui hyper logique qu'à
voler peu de par exemple je prépare
cavaliers des quatre que 5 à 4 ouais
ouais ouais je fixe mon adversaire là et
après deux phrases et 4 watts un jeu
plus toi ouais en plus dans armageddon
tu va le rattraper au temps tu vas
mettre la pression talent et blanc tu
peux aussi bien voir un jour après des
a3b quatre dames à 4 pour aller taper
ici tu as beaucoup de plans différents
tu tiens l'échiquier les maquis
m'apprendra va faire un choix très
étrange il va faire peut décéder
et si on réfléchit bien jeu juste
remettre la position là en réalité on va
échanger lui contre lui et visuellement
on voit que ça va pas trop non parce que
ça cette partie c'est pas du tout aux
joues ta gheskio e cat
on peut apprendre sur des cinq un peu
avancé 5 bloquer le four où je sais mais
c'est juste qu'on rajoute une unité
noire a atteint le jour en tant que
combattant qui a fait peut décéder d'un
des deux dames c'est donc j'ai pas
compris portuaire processus inverse on a
un petit peu avancé tour ac 1-2 qui
protège le pion tour bd 8 en direction
d'un direction mais protège quand même
tous jouent pour le clouage d'amd satis
des cloud en un clin d'oeil h trois
rouages de protège h5 prendre l'espace
typique charia
en plus maxime qui finalement se décide
pour cavaliers 2 pour revenir en jeu ff5
alors là ici vlad cavaliers 4 était
aussi clairement jouable une fois à mort
de 75 là pourquoi on a là rien ne permet
d vient de partir pourquoi pas bien
rocard est très sûr dams et de admettons
prise prises et cavani pour un f2
c'était complètement jouable mais peu
importe on va un petit peu avant ses
cavaliers eu deux fois 5 et 10 km à 15 4
et la vache moins critiquable et
l'arrachement critiquable de la part de
maxime n'ont qu'à ne pas brusquer le 4
était une poker eur calculés jouer votez
à près de 2 après que vous le 2 toutes
les dés du truc a été de mettre le
blocage sur 2,4 ouais ça veut dire qu'il
ya 6 après que vous les 10 4 les bois on
le les noirs ou encore kolo 4 dans ce
cas là peut-être a fait un coup
prophylactiques et toi il y avait 80 oui
et quelques et on aura même peut-être
des g4 un jour parce qu'une fois plus
trop diarra telle menace eux et je
suppose que c'est mieux pour lui le pion
à six qui peut être un peu faiblard les
blancs ils sont mieux est de 1,4 est
trop important que ne case pour ne pas
prendre le contrôle de il a voulu joué
ces six dons qu'il a voulu isoler un peu
le pion des cinq pour plus qu'il soit
protégé par le pion c'est ok c'est 6
hockey dans la salle mais là maintenant
il a vu que h 4 se concurrencent le
court affublé louis leroy hélène jourda
9,4 et qu'est ce qui est arrivé après ta
mort quatre califes cote des cats
le pionner plus blonde est sacré et du
coup on fait maintenant le fouillis et
jusqu'à la fin de la partie le plus on l
a jamais rêvé de l'eurocup
il a pris en 8 une fois les noirs qui
voulait évidemment garder la tour sur la
colonne des ont pris du cavalier tour
des ans pour fixer le pion et h4 et là
c'était peut-être je vais y en est
l'apparition en train de tourner là il
ya encore une chance pour maxime avoue
être relié de st mais il est sûrement
pas view qui ont après fosse 2 tours 2
1 3-10 on fout je cède à ge et fg qui
comprend sûr je sais il ya camry ou
trois fois et tours 2 il est sûrement
pas nous par contre je dois dire qu au
moins six se créa préfère notre coup
après que le toit de il faut gagner il
faut ça il faut gagner encore assez loin
parce que le fougeux de brouiller par ce
genre auquel on assiste
d'où elle bouffe livre la vague que les
cinq fois sacré boulot de gagner ça et
là du coup h4 donc oui car tout est fait
jouer pour s'en prendre aux pions alger
intermédiaire fg à cinq et on voit que
le pion des quatre en plus il bloque un
peu le jeu quoi le problème c'est de
gagner ça parce que le temps coule et
comment est ce que donc réussir dedans
que c'est lent de cette option là et
neutraliser le contenu doit donc les
deux groupes rachat n'ont pas résolu ce
problème parce que après fosse 4 ko les
des six poules de cinq jeux créés a
trouvé un autre trou de la position noir
que les poussins ses revenus vers ces
croyants dont on parlait avec ce cas ces
trois qui est contrôlé à leur fief 3
pour neutraliser sa tour de 6 janvier
ces trois reprises ouais tour des six
tours d2 dodo faut 5 et bah en fait les
blancs rigual visible en réussissent pas
à mettre la marche avant là bas les
pièces noires sont tout à fait
harmonieuse a fait une défend l'autre
puis beaucoup de cases puissant le
centre c33 biome passé et une fois les
bords ont joué ces six le problème c'est
le fou sur f3 en fait qu'il tape nulle
part il est sensible il tape une pale
ale regain de vie de mnm succès à troyes
b 4 à 4 des 5 loubon des changes à
troyes b 4 prises prise tu as du mal à
créer un pion passé là bas tu as
vraiment dit cela parce que c'est le
blocage sur les cases
affaibli pas celle ci serait elle a du
coup on va avancer 1 c'est l'armageddon
ça jouer très vite conquis les trois
fous des trois tours des trois cavaliers
c3 le cavalier qui sautent surprise
prise tour pamfou prend évidemment on
n'est pas moins bien avec les blancs
mais nul c'est une défaite
cette finale de foot couleurs opposées
absolument gagnable n'y a pas le moindre
plan donc maxime qui doit jouer pour
gagner il obligeait à quatre cavaliers
des cinq le carrier qui ressort de
l'autre côté
le problème c'est que une fois le cac
volley sûr que 3 il faut 5 et contre la
cache de trois les pas facile de sortir
le roi et des réussi plus tard mais
hélas pays-bas fois trois tours des 8
pouces et 5 maxime qui se bat comme il
peut quand même qu'ils essayent
d'attaquer les pions cavaliers ou trois
largeurs posco au moins la preuve au jeu
3 2 4 tonnes ouais donc oui maintenant
les noirs arrivent de centraliser leurs
propos fc3f de cd4 maxime qui crée quand
même le pion placé blad on y croit quand
même encore un peu moins auprès
d'artistes d'optimisation de la poudre
gâteau et on voit encore le pion c6 ils
empêchent de contrôler avec 15,8 donc
igem qui a quelque part même un prêt ce
que tu voudrais pouvoir s'en débarrasser
tourbes et 8 x 1 maxime qui tente le
tout pour le tout la tour qui rentrent
en b1 à 5 il envoie le pion les tours 1
il se plaît à gond normalement quand tu
es en face d'un tel collectif des pièces
qu'on tour sur les première deuxième
quart voulait surtout 3 puis on sur
d'éclater faut cinq dons moi qu'est ce
que tu peux faire
ces pièces d'amir juste sur ton
existence et fait tourner trois et
essaye quand même de rentrer peut-être
tour à deux et qui arrive c'est ça qu'on
veut fo de carrier dessin qui veut
repartir rc3 s'en prendre aux fous c'est
difficile la droite 3 il se déclare wife
6 g 4 il en voit peut-être donner un
petit échec de ce côté là puis on prend
qui on prend tour un attaque le foufou
h4 hibon 10 mai g5 des blancs n'ont rien
les pièces noires sont trop active
il repart alors l'ordi propose rouge et
5,3 g 5 tours b 5 mais bon moi après
disons tout à toi wav 2.425
4 bien sûr on peut pas perdre tout un de
contrôle total ouais bon mais maxime
vous qui gardent les pièces fûts f2 on
voit qu'il essaye un vlad d'avancé le
dard section paloise mais l'option va
tomber il va le prendre maintenant
et maintenant les questions c'est avec
watch pour gagner c'est fini peut plus
rien faire que les coûts sont un peu
anecdotique tourbe et huit tours à trois
rois ou 4k valises ses trois échecs roi
detroit alors là y avait juste qu'à
valider un écart et du problème de une
pièce qui aurait fait signer la partie
le risotto de ce fait qu'aider 5 il veut
faire le père pète un joueur en ait du
mal avec les nerfs trois c4 ex'im qui
tente qu'ils b 6 3 des 5
il veut y monte quoi mais détroit le
pion dès qu'ils avancent tranquille food
et un toit attaque le fou fou prend b6
maintenant cb il a finalement créé le
pion passé tour est fixé au 5 contrôle
non ça ouais
r il est fort à tour est fait maintenant
il revient avec la tour 3 des 6 3 6 4 il
repart pour encaisser ce pion des deux
rois des trois fois f4 ok ils tentent au
jour les pièges pasqua à chaque fois
après à peu près d'eux parce que je
crois qu'elle a tout ce qu'il avait si
jamais un tour h1 provoque peut-être
trois tours à trois échecs 3e 4 tours 3
et le joueur français a abandonné
j'imagine qu'après royal saint cloud
tout simple c'est tour cinq échecs roi
monde et tours
oui on ne peut pas défendre à la fois un
chercheur et beurre joueurs français qui
s'inclinent il aura fait un super
tournoi il est très bien placé il a joué
qu'un grand prix il ya que des pots qui
en réalité devant lui mais mais le
français qui est très bien placé qui
même s'il est derrière shahriyar et gris
chucky son premier deuxième mais qui ont
fait de grands prix et le joueur
français qui en a joué qu'un et il fait
avec les peaux sont quand même les deux
favoris mais il ya deux favoris clair
pour les deux places n'est pas nouvelle
mais il ya deux francs-tireurs great
shoot mamediarov donc
attention déjà il faut quand même avouer
qu'il ya il a il n'y a pas trop de
raisons de se vouloir pour ce que s'est
passé pour maxime parce que cas mansouri
qui a égalisé le score il ya tout en
égalisant fait défaut venu relever quand
même sacré accueil news corp et faudrait
donc en quelque sorte des regrets bien
sûr mon gamin pas trop sucrés ou en
totalité à cames et peut-être je sais
moi je crois que dans la cadence rapide
c'était possible un moment donné que et
n'oublions pas que charia dans le
premier grand prix même s'il a gagné ici
avaient pris la bagatelle de 0 points en
perdant premier tour donc le joueur
français qui quand même
voilà ça faudra s'appliquer à hambourg
et tel-aviv mais ça devrait ça devrait
le faire pour pour notre maxime
nationale il faudrait au plus 12 à
tel-aviv en décembre donc ça ne sera pas
trop chaud merci d'avoir suivi ce
tournoi en notre compagnie que ce soit
en direct ou sur les résumés et on se
retrouve très bientôt avec des directs
le championnat de france
achat la sinne que phil cup la coupe du
monde peut-être le swiss grand prix ici
à maxime et bien sûr hambourg et
tel-aviv pour les deux derniers grands
prix
a bientot les gars beissat war